which film set was your greatest teacher
there were two there were two both who
could and both really stretched me one
was a film called the retrieval which
has played us out by Southwest it's a
civil war-era drama I play a bounty
hunter in the 1860s and I'm after
escaped slaves the director wanted me to
be still on the frame and as you can see
by all this it's hard for me to be still
but there's a great power to being still
in the frame and he wanted me to be
still and you wanted me to drop my vocal
range and he wanted almost no inflection
as I spoke to you that's what he wanted
that's what I had to learn to do it was
really devilishly hard but the results
are quite good and the reviews have been
good and I learned that children of
sorrow was a horror film in which I play
a cult leader in the desert by a
director named Jordan McClure who wanted
me to improv I hate improv I hated I
hate it I hate it I'm old school
I need lines which means I'm not a very
good actor but Jordan forced me to
improv and I hated it but it took me to
school and by the end of the shoot I was
completely into the character and it
made me comfortable with it so both of
those were very very difficult things
for me to learn to do to do some improv
and to be still in the frame but both of
them the results were very good and the
reviews for both of them been better
than anything else I've ever done
you